theresa fue hacer paracaidismo la
gráfica de abajo describe la altura a la
que se encontraba theresa medida en
metros como función del tiempo y éste
está medido en segundos así que vamos a
ver tantito la gráfica de la altura que
que a la que se encontraba theresa al
saltar en paracaídas y como podemos ver
al tiempo inicial se encontraba a una
altura de digamos 700 metros verdad y al
saltar pues empieza a descender y cada
vez más rápido y más rápido más rápido
más rápido hasta que llegamos a este en
este momento
empieza a descender con una menor
digamos velocidad verdad esencialmente
aquí empieza a tomar una velocidad cada
vez mayor cada vez mayor empieza a
descender muy muy rápido y después aquí
en este momento algo ocurre algo
repentino que hace que su velocidad
disminuya verdad y de hecho esa
velocidad o la digamos la tasa de cambio
se vuelve constante verdad entonces
podemos pensar que a lo mejor aquí fue
abrió el paracaídas y empezó a descender
a una velocidad constante muy bien y
esto ocurre a los 10 segundos 10
segundos más o menos ok entonces aquí
por ejemplo podemos ver que la tasa de
cambio es muy negativa entonces bueno
eso es digamos el planteamiento que
tenemos de este problema vamos a ver qué
es lo que realmente nos piden nos dice
completa el siguiente enunciado entre 3
y 8 segundos después de que teresa salto
su altura disminuyó en promedio
aproximadamente ya que hay que rellenar
tantos metros por segundo muy bien
entonces vamos a tratar de hacerlo
veamos entre 3 y 8 segundos esto nos
está dando el intervalo en el que hay
que calcular la tasa de cambio promedio
verdad la tasa de cambio promedio en
este intervalo
así que si nos fijamos en el segundo
tres digamos aquí estamos entre 2 y 4
justo a la mitad sería la altura 3
tenemos una altura o más bien teresa se
encuentra en una altura de
aproximadamente que sería bueno entre
600 y 700 sería aproximadamente digamos
si denotamos con h la altura la altura
al tiempo 3 sería igual a o bueno no
igual quizás aproximadamente a 650
metros muy bien y ahora fijémonos al
tiempo 8 en el segundo 8 la altura de
está más o menos digamos ésta es como a
la mitad
aquí estaría 350 y está la mitad de 350
y 400 verdad eso quiere decir que la
altura en el segundo 8 desde bueno si
estamos a la mitad de 350 y 400 serían
y vamos a poner aproximadamente 375
metros muy bien con esta información
nosotros ya podemos calcular cuál es la
tasa de cambio promedio verdad
esencialmente lo que tenemos que hacer
es calcular la pendiente de la del
segmento que conecta a estos dos puntos
muy bien así que vamos a tratar de hacer
eso esencialmente lo que tenemos que
hacer es calcular la división del cambio
en la altura entre el cambio en el
tiempo muy bien y el cambio en la altura
es muy fácil de ver por ejemplo es
simplemente tendríamos que calcular la
altura el tiempo 8 menos la altura del
tiempo 3 y acá dividimos entre el tiempo
8 menos el tiempo 3 muy bien ahí lo
tenemos y esto es esencialmente la
pendiente de este segmento muy bien
entonces nosotros ya sabemos cuánto vale
la altura en el segundo 8 estos son 375
metros y la altura en el segundo 3
digamos es de 650 metros
8 - 3 esto es fácil estoy simplemente 5
y esto que nos queda bueno tenemos que
restar 375 perdón tenemos a 375 hay que
restarle 650 entonces esto como lo
haríamos bueno por ejemplo si fueran 675
y le restamos o bueno 375 675
sería menos 300 verdad pero no son 300
no son 675 son 650 y es con un menos así
que esencialmente hay que sumarle 25 a
lo que ya teníamos que era menos 300 si
le sumamos 25 tendríamos menos 275
verdad y esto va dividido entre 5 nos
vamos nada más a verificar que en efecto
esto sea el resultado tenemos 375 y 275
nos debe dar 650
y esto es cierto verdad 5 y 5 son 10
llevamos 17 y 7 son 14 y 1 son 15
llevamos 1 2 y 3 son 5 y 1 son 6
exactamente está muy bien esta respuesta
ahora bien tenemos simplemente que
dividir 275 entre 5 y eso por ejemplo lo
podemos hacer de esta forma podemos
dividir entre 5 y cuántas veces cabe 27
en 5 pues cabe cinco veces verdad así
que 5 por 5 son 25 los restamos y nos
quedan 2 verdad y bajamos el 5 y ahora
nos preguntamos cuántas veces cabe el 5
en 25 y esos son 5 veces de hecho nos
queda un residuo igual a 0
muy bien cabe exactamente entonces 55 y
con este menos no hay que olvidar el
menos menos 55 metros sobre segundo y
son metros sobre segundo porque en el
numerador teníamos distancias mientras
que en el denominador teníamos tiempo
verdad que está medido
segundos y como dijimos hace unos
momentos esto es esencialmente la tasa
de cambio promedio o que en términos
geométricos podemos verlo como la
pendiente de este segmento y la
pendiente es justamente menos 55
entonces vamos a dar la respuesta final
a este problema dice entre 3 y 8
segundos después de que teresa saltó su
altura disminuyó en promedio
aproximadamente 1 estaría nos ha tentado
a poner aquí menos 55 metros por segundo
sin embargo notemos que aquí ya nos está
diciendo que está disminuyendo es como
si aquí estuviera considerado el menos
entonces disminuye exactamente 55 metros
por segundo verdad 55 metros por segundo
quizás si quisiéramos dar la respuesta
de menos 55 nos estarían no sé tal vez
tendrían que preguntarnos la tasa de
cambio promedio la tasa de cambio
promedio
me dio por supuesto de la altura verdad
que en este caso es h y esto debe
indicarse entre que entren los segundos
que estamos considerando verdad de 3
segundos a 8 segundos en este caso la
respuesta si sería menos 55 metros por
segundo entonces espero que con esto
haya quedado mucho más claro de qué iba
el ejercicio